[Applause]
it is a superhero movie yeah and with
superhero movies come
those costumes you get the superhero
costumes so you must be very excited to
think what's my costume
yeah and then i had to wear it
i look like an african jedi and all this
stuff and it was like and then i had to
have a blanket
flipping blanket man like because she's
showing in atlanta
and so it was so hot
that's really cool because i'm in a
superhero movie so we're like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah but like just
sweat my makeup is going all over my
eyes and i'm just like
blinking like this so i wasn't it wasn't
a sexy moment for me i take it out
now a lot of the reviews are talking
about how this film is kind of a game
changer i mean
was there a sense amongst the cast and
the crew
that you were doing something kind of
important when you're making this film
yeah because it's an african superhero
movie
but i've never seen that in my life i
felt that on set we had this waterfall
scene
and it's basically chad um t'challa's
getting caught um
it's the coronation and then everyone
starts singing like
hundreds of actually start singing and
drumming and i just got chills
i was just like i've never like my inner
child was like oh my god
if i saw this as a kid i wouldn't feel
so such like
such like a weirdo or like you feel
weird when you grow up because there's
enough
there's nothing that looks like you on
tv and this is like
90 of the cast have an african accent
including andy circus
it's like everyone's like you know it's
like
it's just this kind of like when i first
watched my inner child was so happy
that this exists you know yeah i think
the reaction people is going to be
amazing i mean
it's this movie will have such a life
it's going to be yeah congratulations
thank you yeah
now talking on uh
game changing things daniel we must
mention uh your last movie for which you
are oscar nominated get out
uh yes look at you clapping
how many times have you seen this movie
you've seen it three times
two times i love it so much and one of
my west wing
brad yeah i just saw him in a picture
yeah
yeah i love him and catherine keener or
all and jordan peele
i love all they're all amazing it's a
great movie because i have to say i
avoided watching because i thought it
was going to be like a proper horror i
thought it would look because
the poster made me think it was like saw
or something but it's
it's so funny and great frights it's
brilliant but
because you were filming black panther
were you aware
of how big the movie was getting no i
kind of ignore things
i kind of like pretending things are not
happening but it came out on my birthday
it came out my birthday and then i was
uh my girl was there he was in atlanta
and i was like oh we gotta watch it in
it we gotta watch it and i went to the
hood
like we went to go right to the heart of
it because jordan really
had like people like african-american
black audiences in mind
when he when he wrote this and then he
was just sitting there
like i snuck in like i just put my hat
low snuck in
and i was just sitting there at the back
and then the reactions were just
crazy there's a bit when i'm trying to
get out of the house and then and then
this woman goes
get the girlfriend get a girlfriend
i'm gonna be like he's stupid
it was funny man it was funny it was
funny it was a good time
but yeah i just i i was so like then i
just went back to set so i just ignored
i didn't know it was a thing until i
come back here
[Music]
you